megan repino she's that
soccer player i guess she's the soccer
player who hates america and she's very
performatively lesbian she went to the
met gala
and she wore or she carried with herself
a clutch purse that says in gay we trust
right not in god we trust in gay we
trust because her god
is
sexual desire and radicalism and
subversion and the overthrow of
traditional order i suppose right
the whole point of it is the subversion
of an ordinary american slogan
and this is supposed to be revolutionary
except except
she's doing it at the met gala
except she's doing it with the richest
most entrenched most establishmentarian
people
in the entire country
she thinks she's upending the tr the
american religion is christianity and
she's going to upend it and make it this
religion about sexual desire no no
her version the lgbt the rainbow flag
the pride the progress that is
the established church that is the
official religion
if i showed up to the met gala in a
dress
i that that would be fine they would be
that would be totally normal but if i
showed up in a dress
or with a clutch purse that said stop
killing babies
or
i don't know even on you could go even
further on that line down syndrome lives
stop killing people with down syndrome
which which the left openly advocates
doing so in the womb i would be escorted
out by security i would never get in the
door because that would be a genuinely
radical slogan it would be a genuinely
revolutionary slogan
if if i
wore a
costume into the met gala that said
we need election integrity to make sure
that every vote counts
defend election integrity laws i would
be escorted out
because the ruling class doesn't want
any of that stuff
the ruling class wants the bread and the
circuses of the megan rapino and the aoc
and the joy read
and they want
they want to keep the show going while
they rule the country
that that is that is the established
church that we're living in right now
because all human conflict ultimately is
theological hey hold up before you go
before you go
maybe leave me a comment on youtube
maybe subscribe here but most
importantly this is what i need from you
okay i'm just talking you mono amano
okay eye to eye face to face man to man
or woman or whatever
head on over to apple podcast at your
spotify google play wherever you get
your podcasts type in the michael
knowles show hit that subscribe button
it's very simple just
just kiss it then it it'll download and
then we can avoid some of the uh
censorship that goes on in certain
quarters we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]